[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
The Joy of Mathematics I'm Toby and I'm
so glad that you could join me today I'm
going to run a few examples across the
bottom of the screen of things that we
will come to understand today
now I understand if you might be having
a little bit of a stressful day today
because it's not often that someone
who's studying logarithms is having the
best of days
not because logarithms aren't great
because they are but because the process
of learning to be tested can sometimes
come with a lot of stress so we're going
to start off this lesson by drawing some
trees on a sloping hill much like the
one behind me today these are happy
little trees and there are lots of
forests around the world filled with
trees each of them different so I want
you to feel your stress melt away into
the leaves of the trees
if we had a tree that was doubling in
size every year then say after four
years it would be sixteen times as tall
as when we started this is not quite to
scale but I think you get the idea now
mathematically we could write that down
and well it is essentially two times two
times two times two is equal to sixteen
you could also write that as two to the
four because there are four twos is
equal to sixteen but there is one other
way that we can write it and that is log
of ace to 16 is equal to four so these
are equivalent this is just our
logarithmic form of this up here it's a
little bit more familiar written like
this and logs are really as easy as that
students often get very intimidated by
logs because the way they're written
it's just something we don't have a lot
of practice with but once they start to
be familiar I would hope they start to
be a little easier if another tree was
to triple in size every year we can draw
him getting bigger here we want to know
how many years it would take until this
tree was 27 times as big as when we
started so
we can write that down as three which
represents that it's tripling this time
as opposed to doubling before three to
the watt and I'll write out unknown
variable as a little tree usually people
write an X here but there's no reason it
can't be a little tree so three to the
what is going to equal twenty-seven well
just using our log rule from before we
could rewrite this as log base 3 of 27
is equal to tree now unknown variable
okay and you might be able to just
figure this one out by sort of thinking
about it but in fact in this case our
tree would be equal to 3 3 to the 3
would be 27 and that's just another
example of using this log notation in
each of these forms there is a base and
exponent and an argument so one way to
remember how to go between these two
things is that the base of the logarithm
is always the same as the base of the
exponent in this case it is three here
we have our exponent and here we have
our argument and what another way that
you could remember how to write this
form out would be to draw a
cross-section of a log
one that has an anti-clockwise swirl on
it and you could follow this pattern
from the base to the exponent to the
argument to remember the same order to
get back to this one up here let the
rhythm of it flow off your chalk like a
log rolling gently down a hill logs will
become good friends of yours they are
useful to understand really large or
small numbers but don't get too friendly
though the log function is only defined
when the base is larger than zero but
not equal to one to see why if we had a
log with a base of one and say the
number two well what could this equal
there is nothing that one ^ would give
you two so in fact this is undefined and
it would be the same if you had log zero
of tune there was no way to have zero to
the power of something giving you two
also if we were to have a negative
number to a fractional power we might
end up with imaginary numbers and that
would be a bit of a mess so because
these choices of base are not reliable
and we consider them a little bit too
flaky they're not included as part of
the function looking back at our forest
if we had a tree again that was doubling
every year but we take a look at it and
it's actually half its size then let's
think about what's going on here so we
could write it down in Log form and what
we could say is log two that 2 again
represents that it was doubling of a
half because it is now half its size is
equal to what well it actually would be
equal to minus 1 because 2 to the power
of minus 1 we
give you a half so this tree has
actually got minus one as I guess it's
time parameter so it's a bit of a
time-traveling tree there but it also
makes sense you know if it's doubling
every year how far do you have to look
back to see you when it was half its
size all you have to look back one year
now we can do one last example with this
tree up here so say I had this written
out which is log 2 of 1 well what's
going on here is that a tree is doubling
in size every year and it is just as big
as when it started its value as one so
how long has it been growing for well it
is actually been growing for zero amount
of time you're looking at it right now
because it is its current size just a
reminder that that in our exponential
form would have been to curl around to
the zero curl back to here is equal to
one there are some special logs our
default spawn log is log base ten it's
so commonly used that it's usually just
written as log such as on your
calculator
we also have logs in their natural
habitat written as Ln of X these are
logs in base E which is Euler's number
and it pops up in cases of exponential
growth and decay so it's really as easy
as that so take a stroll in the woods
and don't let logs intimidate you any
longer I'd like to wish you happy
studying and I hope you have an
absolutely mathematical day
[Music]